l'assaut du capitole le 6 janvier
dernier aurait pu être évité c'est en
tout cas ce que suggère ce nouveau
rapport de 104 pages volleyer ce mardi
par les médias américains
les conclusions de l'enquêté menée par
l'inspecteur général interne de la
police du capitole sont sans appel les
forces de sécurité du bâtiment aurait
été informé de la menace d'une violente
attaque contre le congrès à la
différence de précédentes manifestations
post-électorales la cible des
manifestants pro trump pour le si ce
n'était pas les contre manifestants mais
bien le congrès lui même leur propension
à tirer des suprémacistes blancs des
milices et d'autres personnes prenant
activement la violence pourrait conduire
à une situation particulièrement
dangereuse pour le maintien de l'ordre
et le grand public en général
toujours selon le rapport la police du
capitole
or et été mis en garde dès le 21
décembre des commentaires sur un site
web ou trump sont signalés dans ces
échanges la promotion d'une attaque
contre des membres du congrès ou encore
la diffusion d'une carte du système de
tunnels des lieux
à porter des armes c'est maintenant ou
jamais nous ne pouvons pas leur donner
le choix
un nombre écrasant de soldats armés est
notre seule chance la veille de cet
épisode insurrectionnel le fbi yaïr les
y ait une autre menace provenant d'un
compte anonyme sur les réseaux sociaux
avec une rhétorique très claire ne
laissant aucune place au doute
soyez prêts à vous battre le congrès a
besoin d'entendre le verre se brise et
les portes enfoncées et le sang des
soldats esclaves black live matters et
pontife à se répondre
soyez violent arrêté d'appeler cela une
marche un rassemblement ou une
manifestation
allez-y prêts pour la guerre nous
obtenons notre président ou nous
mourrons rien d'autre pour atteindre cet
objectif
malgré ces avertissements la veille des
faits la police du capitole recevait son
plan de gestion indiqué dans le document
en noir sur blanc
l'absence de menace spécifique connu lié
à la cession extraordinaire des deux
chambres prévues ce jour là la police
reçoit également l'ordre de ne pas
employer de méthodes trop offensive à
savoir l' usage de grenades
assourdissantes
s'ajoutant à cette liste de manquement
l'emploi d'équipements non fonctionnels
et vétuste autant de dysfonctionnements
qui interroge sur la sécurité du congrès
outre atlantique
suite à cet assaut qui a fait quatre
morts et 140 policiers blessés les trois
hauts responsables de la sécurité ont
démissionné et se rejettent depuis la
responsabilité des faits impossible pour
le moment de savoir exactement ce qu'il
s'est passé ce jour là
en attendant ce nouveau rapport ne passe
pas inaperçu il fera d'ailleurs l'objet
d'une audition ce jeudi au congrès
[Musique]